vous savez qu'on a les trois télés neveu
de michael jackson et on a fait une
interview exclusive vaudrait pont pour
montrer le premier extrait cette
interview puisque eux aussi ont vu le
documentaire
ils sont comme jacky sont très choqués
de ce qu'ils ont vu regardez pour moi
c'était au festival de sundance
je savais à propos du procès de jamie
contre mon nom qu'il y a 5 ans attendre
parler du documentaire je pense que
c'était un autre ramassis c'était
décevant parce que nous connaissons wade
on le connaissait avant c'était encore
une nouvelle personne qui a laissé mon
oncle et c'était vraiment décevant ça me
dérange d'autant plus qu'il ne soit plus
là pour se défendre
ils n'ont rencontré personne de l'autre
partie je trouve que ce n'est pas juste
ce n'est pas du journalisme
on appelle ça de la propagande il n'ya
pas d'autre mot pour ça quand tu
apportes un propre point de vue et que
tu me donnes pas l'occasion d'autres
conjurent réponse prend 2 l'ont caché je
les ai vus et je trouve que c'est de la
manipulation émotionnelle
c'est de la propagande c'est tellement
injuste
notre oncle était ce qu'il ya de
meilleur il m'a sauvé la vie j'avais 16
ans ma mère a été assassinée
il n'y avait que mon nom est michael qui
était la plus grosse star du monde qui a
veillé sur moi et mes frères
connaissant le contexte sachant que ces
gars ont des problèmes financiers
sachant qu'ils attaquent pour des
centaines de millions de dollars
c'est dur parce que les véritables
victimes ce sont mon oncle et ses
enfants ce sont les vraies victimes et
ça me met en colère
je voudrais dire qu'ils nous ont donné
une interview exclusive
c'est exclusif au ballon merci bravo 3
derrière parce que ce qu'ils disent
c'est quand même énorme mais il voyait
que son très ému aussi on leur a demandé
leur a dit sur les motivations premières
de ceux qui ont participé à ce
documentaire et pourquoi ça les amène
aujourd'hui à réagir ils y vont au lit
sans langue de bois
on comprend aussi que c'est avant tout
pour protéger leurs familles et c'est
vrai que là où tu là dessus aussi
ils sont assez choqué de ce qu'ils ont
vu dans le documentaire regarde du
réalisateur aux témoins ils ont
travaillé dur pour descendre mon oncle
et je reste intimement persuadé que
c'est pour l'argent et la notoriété
je pense que pour wade c'est pour la
notoriété le réalisateur ne nous a pas
contacté aucun de nous
n'a contacté personne qui connaissait
michael ou était ami avec michael ça ne
parle pas de mon oncle ce n'est pas à
propos de michael jackson donc pourquoi
ça s'appelle living neverland des gaz
les gars menthe ce sont des menteurs et
c'est tellement frustrant parce que
michael était une belle personne un
homme charmant qui a donné des centaines
de millions de dollars à tout le monde
je pense que ça a déjà été prouvé qu'il
y avait tellement de mensonges dans ce
documentaire qu'en faisant un peu de
recherche
tu vois tout ce qui est faux donc si une
partie est fausse il faut tout vérifier
encore t'es gentil il ya plus d'une
partie qu'ils font c'est pour ça qu'on
est là on ne fait pas ça pour le plaisir
sinon resteraient chez nous et on
ignorait tout ça c'est comme ça que font
les jackson d'habitude ils ignorent mais
aujourd'hui il n'est pas là c'est à nous
d'être savoir nous essayons de les
protéger autant que nous le pouvons
ce n'est pas seulement pour eux c'est
pour toute la famille ça nous affecte
tous abbas alors ces témoignages
franchement une interview très très
forte ils voulaient nous expliquer
pourquoi il fallait mettre en garde les
personnes qui regardent ce documentaire
est pourquoi il fallait se méfier des
deux intervenants qui parle de michael
regarde il faut quand même se rappeler
que ce sont des artistes wild est un
artiste
elle est également un acteur james ce
sont des artistes depuis l'enfance ce
sont des acteurs appelons-le était
lequel il joue un rôle avec un
réalisateur qui s'en moquent de l'autre
point de vue ils s'en fichent de la
vérité donc c'est ce que ça donne
ce n'est pas un documentaire c'est un
film ma cousine brandi est sorti avec
wade pendant huit ans je ne savais même
pas ça ce n'est même pas dans le
documentaire
c'était dans son adolescence de 10 à 19
ans c'est en parallèle dans ce qu'il dit
quand il dit qu'il a été abusé
et ils l'ont caché ça a été je pense que
s'il avait à faire un direct ça se
passerait mal pole parce qu'il ne
pourrait pas maintenir leur banc soir
donc tous les directs qu'ils feront
c'est là où les problèmes commenceront
pour eux si vous regardez ce
documentaire fait des recherches après
monk n'est plus là donc faites vos
recherches ceux sur qui porte les
accusations et rappelez-vous les
vieilles à chercher des preuves pendant
13 ans sont venus à neverland plusieurs
fois ils ont tout mis sens dessus
dessous et ils n'ont rien trouvé là il
eu un procès il a été jugé innocent donc
c'est comme si à un certain moment mon
oncle à braver tout ça alors qu'il était
innocent et donc maintenant parce qu'il
est mort maintenant ils veulent dire que
c'est arrivé dit j'aurais mercier jacky
rien parce que l'interview là qu'on a là
et ce que disent les neurones à michael
jackson
si vraiment inédit et c'est très très
fort ils ont vraiment parlé sans langue
de bois et j'ai centre est touchée par
toutes les accusations qui sont voilà
qui ont été faites contre le rouge est
vraiment ils ont vraiment parlé que le
coeur vous allez voir d'autres extraits
il ya plein de gens qui réagissent sur
twitter qu'ils disent c'est complètement
fou l'interview walgreen a il y aurait
pas eu de documentaires s'il était en
vie
wade serait encore en train de
l'accompagner sérieusement il serait
encore en train de danser lorsque mon
oncle aurait pris soin de lui et cinq
mois il me semble qu'ils sont en colère
de ne plus avoir ça pour eux donc ils
ont inventé c'est à bienne et rabat
je dis ça en tant que victimes d'abus
moi-même et tard il l'a été aussi
nous avons été sexuellement abusée aussi
donc je me prends pas ça du tout à la
légère
juste avant la coupure il ya eu un grand
moment on n'a pas relevé
et toi c'est que deux des neveux de
michael jackson ont dit qu'ils avaient
été abusées sexuellement oui c'est vrai
et le camp pro jaxxon les croit sur
parole là il ya aucun doute il dit j'ai
été abusée sexuellement donc c'est
vraiment ici c'est des gens qui ont été
abusées sexuellement par michael jackson
tout d'un coup ils mentent
donc c'est quand même bien avant mais il
y avait deux poids deux mesures mais à
l'avant d'ailleurs j'en ai parlé avant
l'émission on pourrait bien dire ils
mentent on peut très bien dire qu'ils
inventent nakheel a beau mais croyez si
c'est le cas vous pourriez vous être
besoin de vous et vous alors que j'en
sais rien je connais pas le cas je
trouve très très dur excessivement dur
et je pense que c'est votre fond de
commerce
donc moi je préfère vraiment voir ça
autrement moi j'ai jamais gagné de
l'argent grâce à michael jackson
contrairement à vous
vraiment on comprenait vraiment fou
raconte michael jackson a gagné d'argent
grâce à vous énormément les imitations
de prison n'a lui je vous adore je suis
une très grande fan merci je vous le dis
c'est très dur et c'est pour ça que je
vais pas faire une déclaration en même
temps je lui dirai tout à leur ouïe le
pont
voilà michael jackson alors allez-y moi
j'ai juste une chose à dire enfin quand
on dit que là vous venez de dire que en
fin de compte quand c'est eux qui
parlent enfin compte faut que nous les
fans ont dit qu'ils sont heureux
voilà vous les croyez ce qui s'est passé
ça ils l'ont dit accidentellement parce
qu'ils m'ont appelé après
accidentellement et pensez pas une
seconde le dire et moi j'ai été choqué à
la seconde où j'ai entendu c'est ça les
a marqués à vie et leur oncle oui mais
le rond qu il était là pour eux il était
là pour les sauver
et lorsque le meurtre leur maman a été a
été assassiné non leur mère est morte
bon et c'était très grave et michael
était là pour les sauts et croyez moi ma
qu'elle savait tout ça il n'aurait
jamais jamais jamais fait ça il est
excellent avec les enfants je veux bien
croire qu'on peut confondre l'agent t il
et parce que les enfants s'accrochent à
lui sans arrêt nous était toujours là ça
n'arrêtait pas donc lille et il est il
et prenait dans ses bras et tout ça mais
je vais pas appeler ça de la pédophilie
pour autant on peut de 7 dans ce
documentaire vous voilà beaucoup de gens
disent qu'il est à charge on a demandé
au neveu de michael jackson au 3t si
leur avocat avait fait en sorte de
bloquer la diffusion si c'était possible
écoutez leurs réponses ils sont
terriblement peinée et vous allez voir
c'est finalement ce qui les a convaincus
de réagir chez nous en france
regardez cesser complètement me
regardent ils l'ont fait ils ont été
eux-mêmes chedjou
ils ont essayé de les raisonner en leur
disant voilà tous les mensonges de cette
femme on a été au tribunal avec eux
voilà toutes les choses que la juge a
trouvé fossiles et du bio n'en avait
rien à faire moi même avec les avocats
il n'y a aucune loi qui protège michael
contre le mans parce qu'il est mort si
vous êtes en vie alors vous pouvez
attaquer
non à part dans le monde c'est pour ça
qu'on est là et je ne dis pas ça parce
que c'est une télé française je sais que
vous devez être impartiaux c'est là la
différence avec les autres médias
la france cherche dans les deux camps
alors qu'aux états unis l'angleterre
il n'y a pas de loi à propos de la
diffamation des morts ils peuvent dire
dans ce documentaire tout ce qu'ils
veulent
nous ne pouvons pas les attaquer mais
parce qu'il n'ya pas de loi qui les
protège